demain c'est la saint valentin et pour
célébrer la fête des amoureux
nous avons choisi de vous raconter
l'histoire de zalik à la slovène et
andré l'alsacien qui se sont connus sous
les bombes en allemagne durant la guerre
marie-hélène bono et jean moulin les a
rencontrés chez eux où ils les ont
rencontrés chez eux où ils coulent une
retraite heureuse et amoureuse
andré et zalika l'histoire d'un coup de
foudre sous les bombes en allemagne en
1943 lui alsacien raflés par la gestapo
alors qu'il rejoignait la résistance
elle slovène conduite à regensburg alors
qu'elle fuyait belgrade
c'est dans ce camp de travail dans une
tranchée pendant un bombardement qui se
sont rencontrés
j'ai déterré à l'icac était recouverte
de terre tout ça je le les sorties elle
était vraiment vraiment choqué donc on a
fait une première connaissance l'a
ensuite je suis me suis rendu à sa
baraka la baraque des yougoslaves et
alors quand je suis rentré dans la
baraque
alors là pour moi vu le contexte de
l'époque
c'est un enchantement j'entendais une
musique cristalline
je me suis approché et j'ai vu ça dit
qu'à assises et devant l unità je
connaissais pas du tout cet instrument
c'était la première fois que je le
voyais il y toujours donne dans nos
mémoires les autres jours je vois
toujours qu'elle lui et pour moi c'était
un coup de foudre
ce jeune homme puis c'est le retour en
france le mariage en 46 cents belle robe
les vaches maigres le travail l usine 50
ans de vie commune deux enfants et
l'amour comme au premier jour
je parais c'est toujours mes membres il
n'aime toujours pas physiquement on se
rapproche
tous les deux on a besoin l'un de
l'autre et je crois que l'union est plus
forte
j'ai dit un comme atteints comme à
tisser et puis même comme ça dix
huitième roman t'as pas besoin de dire à
tout le monde
un beau c'est vrai
je t'aime ce qu'on veut mais c'est bien
fait